- La manifestation est
officiellement interdite.
Mais du près du métro Chystye
Prudy, au centre de Moscou,
la foule grossit à vue d'oeil,
en ce samedi après-midi.
Et tout le monde frappe
des mains en attendant
le coup d'envoi officiel.
(slogans en russe)
"Honte à Poutine!"
"C'est notre ville!"
"Libérez les prisonniers
politiques."
Leurs slogans varient
et s'enchaînent, alors que
la foule se déplace lentement
vers la place Pouchkine.
Et quelque part dans cette marée
humaine se cache celle qui a
lancé l'appel à la mobilisation
tout l'été.
Téléphone à la main, elle filme
tous ses déplacements, Lioubov
Sobol, 31 ans, est infatigable
et dans la mire du Kremlin.
(slogans en russe)
Avocate de formation,
Lioubov Sobol était candidate
aux élections prévues dimanche,
avant que son dossier soit
rejeté, comme l'ont été
ceux 60 autres indépendants.
Il a même fallu la sortir
de force des bureaux du comité
électoral. Depuis, c'est elle
qui mène la fronde contre
la répression politique qui,
selon Masha Lipman, est devenue
la norme en Russie,
même aux municipales.
Ça fait des années
qu'elle se bat en coulisses
au nom de la liberté.
Elle n'avait que 23 quand
elle s'est jointe comme juriste
au militant Alexey Navalny pour
enquêter sur la corruption
au sein des sociétés d'État.
Son mari, Sergei Mokhov,
Ça fait des années
qu'elle se bat en coulisses
au nom de la liberté.
Elle n'avait que 23 quand
elle s'est jointe comme juriste
au militant Alexey Navalny pour
enquêter sur la corruption
au sein des sociétés d'État.
Son mari, Sergei Mokhov,
un sociologue, a même été
agressé à la seringue
alors qu'elle se penchait
sur les activités d'un proche
du prédisent Vladimir Poutine.
Mais cela ne l'a pas empêchée
de continuer à militer
publiquement. Elle est
le cerveau de la chaîne YouTube
Navalny LIVE qui, avec
ses millions d'abonnés,
se veut l'antidote à
la télévision d'État.
Quoiqu'encore méconnue
du reste de la Russie,
elle dérange le Kremlin.
Sauf que Lioubov Sobol demeure
une des rares figures
de l'opposition qui n'a pas été
en prison. Quoique plusieurs
fois arrêtée...
Comme sur cette vidéo,
où elle filme les policiers
qui défoncent sa porte.
Chaque fois, elle a été libérée
sur le champ, car la loi russe
interdit l'emprisonnement
des mères de jeunes enfants,
à moins d'un crime grave,
et elle a une fille de 5 ans.
Et la voilà, à quelques jours
des élections, défiant
les policiers.
Elle sera arrêtée à nouveau
et détenue quelques heures
deux jours plus tard,
en sortant de magasin.
Mais l'intrépide avocate
n'a pas dit son dernier mot.
Elle se veut pour le moment
le visage d'un mouvement
qui n'a aucun chef.
"Je ne l'a connais pas assez
pour la considérer une leader,
dit cette manifestante,
mais je partage certainement
sa colère."
Mais le simple fait de tenir
tête au régime, en Russie,
est un pari risqué.
Ses efforts et sa ténacité font
d'elle une force en présence,
incontournable.